der traum von der
überlichtgeschwindigkeit er kommt direkt
aus hollywood und unzähligen science
fiction storys ob mit dem rock drive dem
hyper drive oder der tages wer im
weltall nicht hunderttausende jahre lang
fliegen will muss schneller seien als
das licht
aber geschichten und fiktionen sind das
eine die echte welt mit richtiger
wissenschaft das andere kann man in der
wirklichen welt schneller fliegen als
das licht
hey leute hier strikt vom kanal doktor
watson
christoph hat mich nochmal gebeten eine
folge für ihn zu übernehmen und wie
immer mache ich das natürlich gern
also fangen wir direkt an ihr wollt
schneller fliegen als das licht
okay aber ich denke mal da hat jemand
was dagegen einsteins
relativitätstheorie sagt unter anderem
aus dass sich objekte und informationen
niemals schneller bewegen können als die
lichtgeschwindigkeit in einem vakuum und
obwohl einsteins aussagen seit
jahrzehnten wissenschaftlich anerkannt
sind wollte er hier sich davon nichts
vorschreiben lassen wie kuba ist großer
star trek fan und ließ sich von rob
drive aus der serie inspirieren er
veröffentlichte 1994 eine theorie
darüber wie man mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen könnte
und das innerhalb der regeln von
einsteins relativitätstheorie denn diese
verbietet wie gesagt nur masse energie
und informationen sich schneller als
licht durch den raum zu bewegen
als tobias theorie ist es aber dass sich
das raumschiff mit dem raum bewegt lass
mich das kurz erklären
seit dem urknall vor 13 8 milliarden
jahren denen sich unser universum und
damit unsere raum zeit aus woher die
energie dafür kommt ist eine geschichte
für ein anderes video aber was das in
der realität bedeutet ist zum beispiel
dass galaxien die weit genug voneinander
entfernt sind sich mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit voneinander
entfernt nicht weil sich die galaxien
selber so schnell bewegen denn die
bewegen sich im vergleich zu ihren
nachbarn sogar recht langsam was
wirklich passiert ist dass sich der raum
um die galaxien herum schnell aussehend
und dabei die galaxien mit bewegt
etwas ganz ähnliches passiert hinter dem
ereignishorizont von schwarzen löchern
hier ist die gravitation irgendwann so
groß dass die raumzeit stark genug
gekrümmt wird um masse mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit zur
singularität hinzuziehen
das thema ist super faszinierend aber
auch ziemlich kopfzerbrechen
wenn ihr also noch mehr darüber wissen
wollt könnt ihr euch mein video dazu
ansehen was passiert in einem schwarzen
loch
ok also wie genau funktioniert der block
3 von alcúdia stellt euch ein raumschiff
vor dass die raumzeit vor sich
komprimiert und hinter sich ausdehnt es
würde eine art blase aus raum entstehen
die sich durch das weltall bewegt alles
was sich in der blase befindet würde von
dieser transportiert werden und das auch
mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit das spricht
aber nicht gegen einsteins
relativitätstheorie
da sich das raumschiff relativ zum raum
in dem es sich befindet gar nicht
bewegen würde ein stück raumzeit selber
fliegt mit dem raumschiff darin durch
das weltall der einzige faktor der die
geschwindigkeit reguliert ist die stärke
der wab blase vielleicht kann man sich
das vorstellen wie ein fließband im
supermarkt alles was ich darauf befindet
bewegt sich relativ zum fließband gar
nicht es liegt einfach nur da es ist das
fließband selber das sich bewegt soweit
zur theorie
es ist ein kleiner frecher schlenker um
einsteins relativitätstheorie herum aber
ist der web drive wirklich möglich
vielleicht es gibt jedoch definitiv so
einige probleme die wir lösen müssen
bevor wir durch das weltall rocken
können zum einen dass wir für unsere
blase einen ring mit negativer
energiedichte um unser raumschiff herum
aufbauen müssten auf einem
mikroskopischen level ist das bereits
möglich und experimentell mit hilfe des
kasimir effects erreichbar
ob dieser effekt aber auf makroskopische
ebene funktioniert um menschen zu
transportieren
weiß man noch nicht hierfür bräuchte man
wahrscheinlich eher materie mit
negativer masse etwas das wir noch nicht
gefunden haben und vielleicht auch nie
finden werden
und vielleicht hat das auch seinen grund
denn laut stephen hawking ist so ein web
drive sowieso unmöglich
es könnte nämlich zeitreisen in die
vergangenheit ermöglichen und damit die
chronologie der ereignisse durcheinander
werfen dort hawking verhindern die
gesetze des universums solche kausalität
probleme schon auf einer sub atomaren
ebene
das könnte sich zum beispiel dadurch
bemerkbar machen das alles innerhalb der
it blase durch die hawking strahlung
gebraten wird
aber gut es kann ja sein dass sich
hawking hier irrt und dinge wie
zeitreisen doch möglich sind oder der
rock drive ermöglicht gar keine zeit
reisen da er ja innerhalb seiner
raumzeit unterhalb der
lichtgeschwindigkeit bleibt wie dem auch
sei ein letztes problem bleibt trotzdem
noch wenn man mit seiner rock blase
losfährt muss man zwangsweise teile
seines rings mit negativer energie
zurück lassen
auf dauer würde man so wieder an
geschwindigkeit verlieren man könnte
aber als lösung eine web autobahn bauen
auf der diese materie bereits liegt und
alles schön für den flug vorbereitet ist
aber um diese zu bauen muss man erstmal
mitunter lichtgeschwindigkeit die
komplette strecke abfahren und das
dauert aber dann könnte man theoretisch
durch das weltall sausen
vielleicht es ist wirklich nur eine
theorie aber schreibt mir doch mal in
die kommentare was ihr mit eurem eigenen
brandneuen web drive machen würde so
würde man hinfliegen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
schaut auch gerne mal auf meinem kanal
vorbei auch doktor watson lade jeden
donnerstag videos wie dieses hier hoch
das letzte video ist was ist leben
ich freue mich auf euch bis dann euer
cedric